we are going to introduce a brand new
segment that i'm doing with my partner
producer alex clark and i'm really
excited about this
we're calling it hashtag grand goals
where we're going to highlight the
amazing things that grandparents are
doing out there
and we're kicking it off with janet
lively and she has six kids
11 grandkids and three great grandkids
but what makes her so special amongst
many other things is she just graduated
college
at the age of 75. yeah
i know right take a look at what her
whole family had to say about her
hi drew i wanted to nominate my
grandmother for your segment grand goals
at the age of 75 she just graduated
college
she's such an inspiration to all of us
and her family
way to go grandma i love you so much i
love you monkey
and i'm so proud of you for graduating
love you
grandma love you mom it was fun to be
here cheerleader because she was always
our cheerleader growing up and putting
all the kids first and we're so proud of
her she's such an inspiration to the
girls to watch
after going to school and working so
hard on something she wanted
way to go congratulations on graduating
it has been such an honor watching her
go through this whole process for the
last eight years
great job janet we love you good job
[Music]
the grand matriarch joy janet is joining
us now that's a tongue twister
janet is joining us hi janet are you
there
yes i'm sorry that that got to me
thank you so much drew i'm i'm seriously
so excited but haven't
uh haven't all my kids
give their feelings and they have been
such a support and so excited and
especially about being on this show
thank you so much
oh that to me by surprise seeing all
those kids
with that recording thank you so much
what an incredible
legacy that you have built
i mean you know so
you went to high school and then you
know
what inspired you to go back and get a
degree
at 75
well i have always wished i could go to
college you know
it was so funny when i was in school
they were having a survey about
are you a first first generation
college graduate and i go i don't know
how to respond to that because
i'm the last generation you know all my
kids went before me but my parents
didn't go but anyway
i love learning i i've enjoyed reading
so many books over the years and
i've just always been into history so
when the opportunity presented itself i
had to go for it
and um in the state of georgia i think
it's part of the hope scholarship
they offer excuse me
they offer free tuition you can when you
retire you can qualify for a scholarship
to go to college
for free and you only have to buy your
books so
that was step one
but then there's a lot of other at my
age
there's a lot of other ingredients that
go into this
step one was finding out i could go to
college for free
you know i mean i've got all my kids out
of the house but i still can't
um afford two thousand dollars per
semester for college
but i have i have good health
so i mean like my husband had like four
surgeries in the past
half a dozen years so he it would have
been hard for him to do it but
i've got good health i've got
transportation the college is in a close
proximity to me
and janet i've got it too we're giving
each other frogs in the throat
and during the dawn of covid a sneeze
and like a
throat clearings like ah but you know
something that you
have taught and i'm i never went to a
formal college either i didn't go to
formal high school
um and i really do want to go back and
get my ged
it's something that i'm i'm very much
seeking um
in the world and i have to say that i'm
really excited because
you taught alex clark and i the producer
um about all these colleges in different
states in our country
that actually have this
program in place and i had no idea about
it
so if you go to our website at
thedrewberrymoorshow.com
what will happen is you're going to find
a list and the aarp
also has a list on their website but
come on over to ours
if you like and we're going to give a
full comprehensive list of
every state that provides this free
tuition
to people that i have to say honestly i
didn't know about this so
janet you've taught us something in this
process
and i just think your story
is so amazing that you seek knowledge
you're a history buff and i believe
that's what you got your degree in
yes um world history i wanted to learn
everything about the whole world
well i think that you are an example
to the world of someone and another
detail that i have to say i discussed
with uh alex and i think we could all
benefit from this
is that when you went into it you had a
different mentality because
i heard that you would see the younger
students and you would know that they
were kind of like
nervous about everything and you were on
the other side and had lived life
can you tell me about that really
quickly
it yeah i i'm doing it was a labor of
love for me
and i enjoyed every minute this
uh in four-year college it's right down
the road from me
um it was easy access
and the kids there were under a lot of
stress i felt so badly for the kids that
are carrying a full load
of four and five classes per semester
plus working plus having
you know social relationships and
i was just taking two classes per
semester
but then i was also babysitting my
youngest grandson at the time
two days a week so that was kind of like
a full-time job
i mean a part-time job but yeah it
i felt for the kids that were carrying a
full load
i just think it's so amazing because
when you're younger in some ways you
think you're immortal and invincible
which is super fun
but you also don't know because you're
not old enough to have that
calm wisdom so when you would look at
these young students and their stress
and have
the benefit of having lived a full life
and choosing to create this legacy of
everyone you saw in that video
there was something about your
interpretation of watching them
with your life experience that i had a
real takeaway from
and i just think you're so amazing and
we wanted to make sure you have a
wardrobe
to go out there and flaunt that degree
so that no matter where you choose to
go or what you choose to do with this
fabulous degree
talbots is actually giving a five
thousand dollar
gift card to you and kidding me
a personal styling appointment so that
you can go out there and work that
degree
oh my goodness i pulled my cord
fantastic listen janet it's about
pulling cords and crying
this is great i love this segment
oh my stars thank you that it's amazing
thank you so much no janet you're
[Music]
amazing
you